*смажені ковбаски
*макарони з яєчного тіста
*печеня з маринованого м'яса
*м'ясний рулет
*швабські пельмені
*картопляне пюре та яблучний мус із ковбасою
*свиняча рулька
Дозвольте мені із німецькою чесністю розповісти,
що я думаю про традиційні німецькі страви.
Вони зазвичай калорійні, доволі м'ясні, а за кольором варіюються від бежевого до коричневого.
Німецька їжа переважно смачна, але на вигляд не дуже.
Подивімося, що скаже на це німецький гурман...
Я також працюю кулінарним фотографом, і знімати який-небудь гуляш -
це зовсім не просто. Але, як не дивно, саме такі страви майже усі вважають
"їжею для душі". Тобто страва, яка викликає приємні відчуття й спогади, -
це дуже часто саме печеня або шніцель. Яка різниця, які вони на вигляд?
Головне - тобі від цього добре.
- Як би ти описав традиційну німецьку їжу?
- У німецькій страві завжди є гарнір.
Картопля або макарони мають бути обов'язково.
Класика мого дитинства - від бабусі й дідуся - макарони зі смаженою картоплею.
Вуглеводи з вуглеводами.
- А що ти приготуєш для нас?
- Сьогодні буде шніцель. Ми його часто їли, коли я був маленьким,
це була найбільш типова німецька страва.
Шніцель прийшов до Німеччини, звісно, з Австрії.
Німеччина межує з дев'ятьма різними країнами,
які дуже впливають на прикордонну німецьку кухню.
Серед німців є фанати таких сезонних продуктів як спаржа, полуниці, вишня або капуста.
У сезон кучерявої капусти німці навіть збираються на спільне споживання
тушкованого капустяного листя з ковбасою.
Барбекю - сезонна страва?
У Німеччині навесні, коли починає припікати сонечко, відкривається сезон грилю.
У першого барбекю року є навіть власна назва…Angrillen
І, згідно з опитуваннями, в Німеччині 97% населення смажать на грилі!
Ключові компоненти німецького барбекю: багато м'яса, картопляний салат,
гірчиця й булочки, в яких неможливо вмістити ковбаску.
Що ще ми знаємо про німецькі смакові уподобання?
Улюблене м'ясо німців - свинина.
Близько 5% населення - вегетаріанці й 1% - вегани.
Найпопулярніші овочі - помідори, морква, цибуля й огірки.
Улюблені фрукти - банани, яблука, апельсини й дині.
Картопля шанується в усіх її видах.
"Картоплею" навіть називають когось, хто надто "німецький".
І, нарешті, трави й спеції, які часто використовуються в німецьких рецептах:
петрушка, кріп, а в деяких регіонах - тмин.
Гаразд,з цим розібралися. Тепер твій хід, Сашо!
Класична послідовність паніровки: cпершу обвалюємо м'ясо в борошні,
далі занурюємо у збите яйце, а тоді - в паніровку.
У нас тут суміш пластівців і "панко", що кумедно, тому що "панко" - це японські хлібні крихти,
і, на мій погляд, це добрий спосіб дещо модернізувати класичні німецькі страви.
Тепер обсмажуємо по дві хвилини з кожного боку
на середньому вогні - в жодному разі не на сильному,
аби злегка шкварчало під час обсмажування.
Картопля смажена, фрі або відварна - як хочете.
І от наш шніцель готовий!
Смачного бажають словами "Guten Appetit" - "доброго апетиту" -
чи більш розмовним варіантом "Guten Hunger" - "доброго голоду".
А хочеш показати себе справжнім німцем? Тоді скажи Mahlzeit!
Буквально це означає "час прийому їжі".
В обідню пору це цілком прийнятне привітання.
У відповідь також кажуть "мальцайт".
Ммм... Смачно!
До речі, про прийоми їжі...
Сніданок ділить німців на два табори: тих, хто їсть бутерброди з ковбасою,
яйцями, сиром та чимось солодким. І тих, хто любить мюслі, пластівці й кашу.
В обідній час традиційно їдять гарячу їжу.
Я виросла на холодних закусках, на сендвічах, і досі не можу звикнути.
Хоча б тому, що дуже довго треба приходити до тями після величезної порції
гарячої німецької їжі в їдальні.
Багато німців обідають дуже рано.
У мене є колеги, які йдуть на обід ще до опівдня.
На вечерю можуть бути просто бутерброди. Їх навіть називають Abendbrot,
що перекладається як "вечірній хліб".
Чесно кажучи, нагадує ще один сніданок. Але звички змінюються,
і приблизно третина німців тепер гарячу їжу споживають увечері.
Згідно з недавнім дослідженням, ¾ німців люблять готувати.
У часи до локдауну кожен другий ходив у ресторан щонайменше раз на місяць,
а кожен четвертий їв фастфуд раз на тиждень.
Інтернаціональна кухня в Німеччині відображає історію імміграції.
Німецька назва закусочних Imbiss в давнину перекладалася як "прийом їжі".
А чим німці перекушують? Частіш за все це шоколад і чіпси.
Ось чого мені ніколи не зрозуміти, то це їхньої пристрасті до чіпсів з паприкою…
Втім, про смаки не сперечаються.
Гаразд, а що на десерт?
На жаль, десертам у Німеччині не приділяють належної уваги.
Але не бійтеся, любителі тортиків!
Тут є таке поняття як Kaffee und Kuchen (кава з пляцком).
Ця традиція з'явилася ще у 17-му столітті.
Каву з пляцком часто п'ють у другій половині дня з батьками або бабусями-дідусями.
Для повноти відчуттів можна використовувати старовинні сервізи й десертні виделки.
Знаменита німецька випічка:
Вишневий торт зі Шварцвальда
Пиріг с мигдалем "Бджолиний укус"
І "Мармуровий кекс"
А що вам подобається чи не подобається у німецькій кухні?
Напишіть у коментарях!